[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous en vivez
ça c'est la question que le moment on
pose soit en deuxième position soit en
première position est-ce que vous en
vivez il y a des mots importants dans
cette phrase et dans cette question
et j'ai hésité à prendre plusieurs axes
en répondant à cette question tout
simplement parce que je n'y réponds
jamais c'est une question que je ne
réponds pas je sais pourquoi je vis je
sais ce qui me fait vivre mais est-ce
que j'ai envie tel que les gens me
posent la question on sait bien de quoi
ils veulent parler
et donc souvent je réponds pas et je
réponds naïvement et je vais un petit
peu ce soir le prendre au premier degré
ce qui est assez exceptionnel puisque je
n'y réponds jamais
[Musique]
j'ai pris un axe
parce que j'avais écrit déjà un texte
une trame et les événements de la vie
comme chez tout le monde encore
récemment dans ma propre vie m'ont fait
dire que j'étais pas aussi honnête que
d'habitude aussi intègre que dans mon
métier qu'entre mes quatre murs
dans mon huis clos là où je travaille
je vais faire attention j'essaye d'être
vigilant et toujours intègre dans ma
démarche et là j'allais pas être un
texte ce soir donc c'est bien d'être
devant vous et en même temps j'avais pas
écrit je pense les bonnes choses donc on
va être transparent
je convoque quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup
aidé quand j'étais un peu plus jeune
quand j'ai découvert un peu la
philosophie je ne suis pas philosophe
Jean-Paul Sartre quand tu peux connu et
j'ai tout simplement aimé j'ai retenu
une de ces choses
qui met en principe que le destin c'est
pas quelque chose qui est devant nous
c'est pas que chose qui serait écrit à
90%
, il a un regard qui est complètement
différent et qui m'a toujours suivi
depuis que j'ai lu une partie de ces
textes c'est le destin pour lui je vais
essayer pas trop vulgariser c'est plutôt
ce qui est derrière nous
c'est travailler à l'envers c'est
travailler par constat c'est se dire le
destin c'est pas tout ce que il me reste
à écrire c'est je me retourne
et par constat factuellement voilà ce
qui a été ma vie voilà ce qu'est ma
destinée jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc moi le thème perspective je vais
pas parler de ce qu'il y a devant moi je
sais où je veux un peu aller tout n'est
pas écrit encore je pensais un peu
pareil pour tout le monde on fait avec
les contraintes et puis on fait aussi
avec nos choix et nos engagements alors
je vais commencer d'y répondre et je
vais être donc le plus transparent
possible et intègre
donc on va regarder dans un premier
miroir vous verrez je parle
régulièrement de miroirs et qui prennent
différentes formes chez moi
le premier miroir c'est facile c'est le
miroir du rétroviseur on va parler un
petit peu on va remonter un petit peu
quelques années j'ai pas très vieux on
va remonter mais 12 ans
mais 12 ans c'est l'âge où ma maman
ma sœur
et moi on décide de virer notre père de
chez nous
un père violent
qui est violent
et on a une mère qui nous aime
et donc je grandis avec sa créature à
deux têtes et on a coupé une tête celle
qui nous intéressait plus et on a mis
notre paire dehors avec la complicité de
notre mère avec l'amour de notre mère et
j'ai 12 ans
et là ma vie elle commence
ma destinée commence et mon métier
d'aujourd'hui je suis déjà en train
d'écrire sans le savoir
on est déjà sur une forme d'engagement
on a une mère qui nous fait confiance
puisque elle peut poser les questions à
ses enfants savoir si nous on est
d'accord avec son jugement et on répond
oui spontanément donc on fera sans lui
donc à partir de mes 12 ans je ne
reverrai plus jamais mon père ce sera
pareil pour ma sœur et le seul nouvel
que j'aurais plus tard c'est à son décès
en 2020 et j'ai ressenti quelque chose
j'aimerais ressenti c'est l'absence de
tristesse
c'est l'absence de sentiment quelque
chose qui était totalement inédit chez
moi il faut savoir que dans mon métier
qui est censé me faire vivre
je travaille sur l'émotion
et une violence dernière petite violence
le dernier petit coup de vin de mon père
il m'enlève même le fait d'être presque
content alors c'est pas bien de le dire
ça c'est pas très
[Musique]
politiquement correct mais en tout cas
j'ai aucun remord à ce qu'il passe
et donc là la vie elle devient beaucoup
plus facile on devient plus serein à la
maison on a une créature à une tête
aimante qui est notre maman et donc là
c'est déjà tout de suite plus facile je
grandis je me passionne pour le football
je suis la génération d'avant 98
j'ai déjà pratiqué le football par le
regarder vraiment être dans l'action pas
dans l'idée et le concept de l'image
qu'on regarde et de supporter j'ai
jamais été avec les écharpes et les
maillots j'ai préféré le porter d'être
dans l'action tout de suite d'être
acteur de se divertissement là je
préfère marquer les buts faire la
dernière passe décisive plutôt que de
regarder les replays et aujourd'hui
l'avare qui est exceptionnel puisqu'on
revoit de 15 fois la même action et on
sait toujours pas où on va
je passionne pour le football le
football
m'offre une opportunité c'est que je me
je me retrouve dans une situation où ça
marche plutôt bien pour moi je me
retrouve dans une classe foot alors
c'est pas le sport là dessus la classe
foot c'est tout le temps libre et voué
au football en dehors de l'école et plus
vous êtes aussi inscrit dans un dans un
club de football c'est à dire que vous
faites 15 heures de football par semaine
je trouve l'amour de mes collègues je
trouve beaucoup d'hommes autour de moi
des jeune homme comme je suis et je
côtoie beaucoup de coachs aussi c'est
effectivement plus je monte dans les
classes plus plus les coachs sont
sérieux et paternel
alors
je pense être honnête en disant que
jamais chercher de pair parce que mon
père ne m'a jamais manqué et un père ne
m'a jamais manqué c'est là où ma mère a
performé ma mère elle a essayé de
combler je pense qu'elle a réussi dans
ce domaine là à la combler beaucoup de
choses la seule chose qu'elle a pas
réussi à faire c'est apprendre à me
raser quand on se rase je me coupe
encore donc vous voyez je suis pas très
bien rasé et puis je suis pas
spécialement envie d'apprendre à raser à
me raser voilà mise à part ça le reste
je pense c'est assez complet ma mère
était un petit peu sur tous les fronts
comme une mère aimante
et le football se passe bien je monte
les classes je suis surclassée et je
prends plaisir avec des gens plus âgés
et là
c'est pas encore je continue à écrire
mon métier d'aujourd'hui je côtoie des
gens je suis curieux des profils je suis
curieux de savoir parce que chacun de
vie chez soi surtout quand on parle de
son père quand on voit les pères aller
voir mais mes camarades au football je
suis aussi fier de jouer
devant leur père c'est assez étrange
qu'on fait la même et donc je comble un
petit peu comme ça ce mot qui qui a
priori n'était pas vraiment très présent
et
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui va me suivre
jusqu'à un manque de d'envie
c'est-à-dire que le football je sens que
je suis pas très bon au bout d'un moment
je sens que mes limites sont atteintes
assez vite j'ai une vingtaine d'années
donc j'arrête j'ai moins envie d'aller à
vous entraînements quand on a plus envie
de s'entraîner on se retrouve plus
sélectionné pour les matchs quand vous
êtes plus sélectionné pour les matchs
vous avez plus envie d'aller vous
entraînements et donc cette passion là
parce que c'était une passion elle part
petit à petit mais je garde toujours ce
contact de d'aller poser les questions
un petit peu pas que sur les paires
aller poser des questions et et d'avoir
cette empathie là de savoir comment ça
peut se passer derrière tel ou tel
profil garçon ou fille c'est aussi ce
que nous a transmis notre mère
c'est-à-dire qu'on a quelque chose ma
mère beaucoup de monde à aller la voir
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de monde va
se confier à elle et sans savoir nous a
aussi transmis ça donc autant des filles
que les garçons des hommes des femmes on
se confie à moi c'est facilement même
les personnes que je connais pas
beaucoup
je pourrais pas tous vous écouter ce
soir
je suis pas psychologue non plus mais je
prête oreille et je sais que ça fait
aussi partie mon métier aujourd'hui
le football s'arrête mais j'ai gagné
voilà des pères provisoires des pères
par intérim et en plus le luxe qu'on a
dans ce cas de figure c'est qu'on
choisit un petit peu qui on a envie donc
des gens qui performent dans un sport
que j'aime bien pour certains qui m'ont
emmené après dans des événements un peu
plus importants donc on rencontre
d'autres personnes d'autres métiers
aussi des personnes très différentes
j'enchaîne je grandis là on est dans les
années 2000 je passe mon bac c'était ma
mère c'était pas ton bac comme beaucoup
de mamans et je restais le bac je vais
essayer le concours d'entrée au
Beaux-Arts à Saint-Étienne je suis
stéphanois j'ai grandi ici je travaille
toujours ici aussi
et les Beaux-Arts se passent plutôt bien
je termine mon cursus à la faculté
d'arts plastiques pendant ce temps là je
paye mes études en partie on est en DJ
en boîte de nuit
la nuit donc du jeudi au samedi je
travaille la nuit donc faut imaginer que
ça il va donner un peu ma classe à
l'époque donc on travaille en costume je
porte quasiment plus de costumes
je sortais à l'époque on avait des
grandes mallettes parce que le matériel
était plus était physique on n'était pas
dans le que dans le digital et je
sentais que mes mallettes en costume et
j'allais à la fac le matin je dormais un
petit peu je cache pas je peux les notes
étaient prises un peu à la façon
aléatoire mais
ça se passait bien
j'ai une rupture dans ma vie j'ai
accompagné pendant cinq ans mon
ex-compagne qui à un moment donné
m'apprend qu'elle est dépressive
chronique et dépression je connais pas
ce que ça a dépression parce que notre
mère nous a toujours transmis quelque
chose d'optimiste le fait d'aller durer
d'aller chercher ce qui peut nous
apporter les choses et ce que nous peut
apporter aux gens et les deux dernières
années ma compagne va vraiment pas bien
et me quitte décide que je puis l'aider
et c'est une période qui est très
difficile pour moi je vais avoir mon
diplôme je suis dans ma dernière année
donc je me suis en 5e année
je me sens pas bien je m'isole aussi
puisque quand vous êtes invité avec une
compagne qui était précise la campagne
veut pas venir au bout d'un moment
nous-mêmes on sort plus on voit plus
personne donc on se la priorité et que
ça accompagne reste vivante au quotidien
c'est ça
et c'est à l'opposé de ce que nous on
est on n'a pas été éduqué comme ça on
est des résilions l'être humain je pense
est résilient par nature et après
peut-être avec un peu d'éducation et de
et de culture ou d'entourage on regagne
un petit peu cette instinct survie et
bon mission compliquée je me retrouve
seule je me retrouve sur mon diplôme je
me rends compte comme mon diplôme va
m'amener vers quelque chose que
et je côtoie au milieu de boîte de nuit
des personnes qui sont très bien je
commence aussi à parfaire mon métier
puisque je me rends compte qu'en boîte
de nuit c'est
j'attends en discuté avec du monde des
gens très heureux des gens faussement
heureux des gens qui sont faussement
triste parce que c'est un peu bu les
gens vraiment triste qui viennent du
jeudi au samedi toujours avec le même
costume qui me racontait même chose tous
les soirs pendant que moi je travaille
en fait je suis là pour amuser la
galerie
et donc il y a cette cette opposition
qui est discuté avec des gens avec des
fois en difficulté des fois dans leur
bonheur à eux mais je suis content
d'être là en fait moi je m'amuse et en
plus j'ai le temps de prêter oreilles à
ça
et je côtoie un moment donné on est en
fin diplôme de 2009 je côtoie pas
toujours les bonnes personnes et
je côtoie quelqu'un pour le coup pour
sauver un petit peu ma légitimité
quelqu'un qui est dans ma famille donc
on choisit ses amis mais pas sa famille
et se met à a priori à faire des
cambriolages ça je la prends plus tard
j'ai la peur je la prends lors d'un
procès
cela peut j'apprends pendant le procès
que la personne de ma famille qui a une
cinquantaine d'années à l'époque
a changé de métier est devenu
cambrioleur
mais j'en sais pas plus
et pourquoi j'apprends ça puisque moi on
est venu me chercher aussi
et un deuxième miroir qui apparaît dans
ma vie c'est la confrontation au moment
où vous êtes sur un cursus qui
fonctionne bien vous faites vous êtes
heureux je suis dans un domaine qui est
plutôt artistique j'ai fait les études
que je voulais ma mère m'avait dit tu
vas jusqu'au bout contre un rempli
ce que j'avais pas compris c'est qu'elle
me disait va jusqu'au bout de la
démarche c'était pas juste au bout des
études c'est va rester toi-même jusqu'au
bout donc ce que ça passe par les études
ou pas va jusqu'au bout des choses ça je
comprends un peu plus tard
elle revient au cambriolage
on vient me chercher mais en me mettant
les menottes
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai caché des
preuves par amour de cette personne
et donc ça s'appelle du Russell j'ai
jamais cambriolé j'étais pas au courant
de ce que cette personne faisait mais
j'ai caché des preuves pour que cette
personne fasse moins de prison par amour
c'est le paradoxe je me mets dans la
totale opposition à ce que je suis et à
ce que d'autres merdes vous a éduqué
donc dans la transmission il y a un bug
il y a quelque chose qui est mal passé
je me retrouve avec les menottes et
c'est un miroir là de trouver avec les
menottes c'est une première chose
ce miroir là il m'a poursuivi pas mal
d'années c'est très culpabilisant je
vais conclure avec cette chose là
ça marche ça c'est une sculpture que
j'ai fait en sortant des quatre mois
c'est ma première sculpture
ça symbolise mon vécu
les absences
le mépris quelque chose qui nous dépasse
physiquement psychologiquement
quelque chose qui est dans le vrai
quelque chose qui est nul qui est
présenté de façon un peu canonique c'est
l'anti-héros tout ce que j'ai envie
d'être tout ce que j'ai pas envie d'être
c'est pas un autoportrait c'est le père
je l'ai pas vu
c'est l'enfonc je n'ai pas eu
certains profils
j'ai un peu piocher dans les choses ça
c'est un des premiers dessins que j'ai
fait avant une série de sculpture sur
les loups j'ai traité un peu mon vécu
sous forme de meute de loup mais en me
disant voilà on est tous le chef d'une
meute nous pour nous-mêmes et on est à
la fois celui qui veut vivre tout seul
et en même temps celui qui va vivre en
meute et notre vie est constamment en
fait comme ça puis l'image du loup en
philosophie assez connu
ça c'est mon huis clos je suis artiste
plasticien vous savez souvenez la
question est-ce que j'ai envie
alors je vais commencer d'y répondre
j'en pleure
je me mets en colère
je vis des jours extraordinaires
j'ai rencontré énormément de personnes
je fais des œuvres relationnelles ça je
fais beaucoup d'enquêtes je vais voir
les gens je discute vraiment avec des
gens très différents
d'origine différente de milieu sociaux
différents de nationalités différentes
de religions différentes
je discute avec les individus
et pour me laver de tout ça parce qu'il
y a une énorme culpabilité à mon
parcours au moins tout transmis on va
donner toutes les richesses ma mère a
tout donné c'est sacrifié pour nous elle
nous a éduqué seul être venu féministe
avant MiTo bien avant on est dans
l'année où
quand les femmes allaient porter plainte
on leur disait de rentrer de se calmer
et de rentrer à la maison
ça a commencé de changer un petit peu
ça c'est une photo du ciel donc je fais
un pléonasme
et je me suis dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
si jamais en fait ça se termine
aujourd'hui et moi je voyais pendant des
années des gens au-dessus d'Andrézieux
sautés en parachute pendant que nous on
faisait les merguez avec la belle
famille et je me suis dit ils sont fous
c'est vrai qu'ils sont en bonne santé
ils vont bien sportif ou pas je suis
sportif je monte pas dans un avion pour
faire ça
et 2015 je conclu avec ça et ben on
passe le cap on passe le cap de se dire
en fait quelque chose qui a toujours
fait peur je vais y aller je vais voir
ce qui se passe parce que on sait
peut-être comment on est dans une
situation mais quand on l'a vu on se
redécouvre c'est le troisième miroir
dont je voulais vous parler je reviens
un petit peu en arrière quand vous êtes
dans cet avion qui monte à 4000 mètres
le temps est très long
et vous avez le temps de vous poser
toutes les questions métaphysique et
puis il y en a une autre qui est très
importante c'est en fait qui je suis
est-ce que si ça se passe mal
est-ce que je peux être fier de moi
est-ce que sur mon parcours
c'est plutôt positif
et ça on peut le fantasmer on peut
l'imaginer mais c'est vrai que quand on
se dit qu'on a peut-être une chance que
ça se termine sans que ce soit macabre
attention c'est pas morbide ce que je
dis c'est l'inverse ce contraire on peut
mourir tous les jours à chaque seconde
ce temps là il dure à peu près 30
secondes là on est dans le loisir et là
je prends plaisir je suis content d'être
là je suis heureux d'être à cet instant
là en train de voir
on va dire tout le destin qui qui est
devant et que je moi je vais écrire mais
le plus important c'était l'ascension
c'est le moment où on est monté et donc
pour la première fois de ma vie je
délègue cette confiance et je laisse les
choses à faire
voilà on va terminer sur cette cette
image symbolique le destin on peut tous
l'imaginer sur ce qui va arriver mais je
pense qu'il y a un miroir qui est très
important c'est le dernier miroir dont
je vais vous parler je vais essayer de
conclure rapidement ces miroirs tout
simplement physique c'est le moment où
vous êtes tout seul le soir
je vous propose de faire l'expérience un
jour tu as trouvé déjà fait alors c'est
pas pour vous coiffer moi je suis plus
concerné
c'est de regarder comme on regarde
quelqu'un dans les yeux et l'expérience
dont je voulais vous parler c'est le
miroir le soir c'est mieux parce qu'on a
vécu des choses dans la journée c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous
regardez dans les yeux il y a pas
d'arrière-pensée on n'a pas besoin de
traduire ce qu'on est en train de
ressentir on n'a pas de mots à choisir
puisque c'est vous-même avec vous même
la question c'est savoir qui vous êtes
est-ce que de votre quotidien quel que
soit vos choix et vos engagements et je
parle d'engagement pas d'investissement
l'engagement c'est ce qui
par définition est sans garantie ça
quand vous allez faire des choix il y a
pas de garantie et ça donne une valeur
aux choses ça donne une valeur à vos
engagements à vos choix c'est qu'il y a
pas de garantie et c'est plus dur de se
faire un engagement qu'un investissement
s'il y a des accidents et la seule chose
que je peux vous proposer c'est de faire
cette épreuve du miroir et vraiment de
vous poser la question de façon très
honnête comme j'ai réécris mon texte
c'est de vous dire est-ce que vous en
vivez de ce que vous profession de votre
entourage des choix que vous faites au
quotidien des erreurs vous faites des
réussites des encouragements tous noyau
dur qui est autour de vous qui vous
donne la force d'avancer soit votre
maman votre papa j'espère aussi pour
vous
est-ce que vous vivez
c'est tout pour moi
[Applaudissements]